[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
extrem leckere Cupcake Variation ich
habe mir überlegt einen extrem fluffigen
Vanille Muffin zu machen mit keksbohnen
damit man den Crunch dabei hat und top
ein cream cheese Frosting und
Erdbeerpüree also es wird ultra lecker
und ich starte jetzt direkt wir machen
jetzt ein klassischen Keksboden ich
werde jetzt hier die Butter zerlassen
und die Butterkekse schön mixen
[Musik]
so ich verteile jetzt hier noch Förmchen
in meinen Muffinblech komme 12 Muffins
bzw Cupcakes raus und ich finde es macht
viel zu selten Cupcakes eigentlich ist
cool weil er hat so jeder sein kleines
Törtchen was schönes und vom Aufwand her
fast genauso wie wenn ihr normalen
Kuchen backt also nicht wirklich viel
aufwendiger so jetzt werde ich einmal
den Keksboden gleichmäßig verteilen und
dann unbedingt flach andrücken sonst
kommt so bröckelig am Ende wieder raus
das möchten wir nicht also am besten ein
Armen Ofen und vorgeheizt ganz ganz
wichtig immer schön vorheizen mein ähm
mein teeglass hatte hier so ein ganz
ganz flachen Boden und den braucht ihr
dann damit etwas schön andrücken könnt
ich zeige euch aber dann gleich erstmal
den Vanille Muffinteig und der kommt
dann gleich noch mal hier drüber
[Musik]
und dann kommt das Zimmer warme Butter
rein die habe ich so ungefähr anderthalb
bis zwei Stunden vorher aus dem
Kühlschrank genommen zusammen mit Zucker
natürlich das ganze dann schön cremig
schlagen oder so ein Stückchen
geht aber nicht so zusammen mit Zucker
einer Prise Salz die unterstreicht jetzt
einfach noch mein süßen Geschmack und
weil es ja ein vanilleteig werden soll
gebe ich dann noch Vanilleextrakt dazu
und dann das ganze 2 Minuten lang
schlagen und dann kommt Eier dazu
[Musik]
so die Eier wurden ebenfalls eingerührt
alles richtig gut verbunden und jetzt
kommt Mehl in mein Sieb ich sieht das
immer ganz gerne wenn man weiß ja nie
aufgrund von Lagerung etc aber dann habt
ihr da so Mehl Nester und klümchen und
intensiv gebe ich auch mein Backpulver
wichtig ist jetzt so dass ich alles an
trockene Zutaten in die Masse gibt sonst
wird das ein richtig trockener und
spröder Teig und ähm wir machen so wir
geben Milch abwechseln mit den trocknen
zu lassen Zutaten mit rein genau
Backpulver einmal und dann wie gesagt
einfach abwechselnd in die Masse geben
und dann bei langsamer Geschwindigkeit
schön einarbeiten die Milch sollte im
allerbesten verlaufern sein und dann
kann ich gar nichts mehr schief gehen
oh das ist jetzt neu so
[Musik]
der Teig wird dann am Ende wirklich nur
noch so kurz wie notwendig verrührt also
nicht zu viel rühren das ist gar nicht
notwendig ich gebe jetzt hier noch den
Vanille Teig auf meinen Keksboden ich
finde es ein bisschen aufregender dann
hat man echt noch sowas zu beißen so das
knuspriges dann kommt der fluffige Teig
und top wie gesagt
das ist ganz wichtig 180 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze und die Backzeit beträgt 22
Minuten und ich schreibe euch sowieso
alle ganz genau und Angaben Zutaten etc
immer unten in die Infobox leute das ist
dann ein bisschen einfacher für euch
dann klappt es euch das auf könnte
Screenshot mit einkaufen gehen und wir
nutzen aber die Zwischenzeit weil sie
müssen ja danach noch abkühlen und
machen dann das Screenshot und das
Erdbeerpüree
[Musik]
mein creampie's Frosting besteht aus
vier Zutaten ganz wichtig ist dass die
Butter die wir jetzt benutzen Zimmer
warm ist also rechtzeitig dran denken
sie aus dem Kühlschrank zu nehmen und
die wird jetzt erstmal alleine bzw
könnte eigentlich schon Vanilleextrakt
hinzugeben aber das mache ich gleich
erst die wird jetzt erstmal geschlagen
und zwar so ungefähr 3 Minuten lang
bisschen cremiger ist
[Musik]
so ihr habt die Wahl aus
Doppelrahmfrischkäse und Mascarpone also
Mascarpone ist italienischer Frischkäse
und ich habe heute Mascarpone genommen
weil das auch einfach neutraler schmeckt
und den Vanillegeschmack noch mal super
annimmt jetzt kommt da eigentlich nur
noch Puderzucker dazu und den siebig
rein also ich gebe da auch alles auf
einmal rein und rühre das nur noch mal
so eine gute Minute und dann ist das
Frosting auch schon fertig je nachdem
wie warm es bei euch in der Küche ist
also gerade wenn ihr so im Sommer zum
Beispiel das ganze macht dann kann es
sein dass ihr das noch mal für 10
Minuten in den Kühlschrank geben müsst
bevor ihr das aufspritzen könnt bei mir
ist es gerade ganz normal also nicht zu
warm da kann ich sofort verwenden
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt Erdbeerpüree das
brauchen wir später fürs Frosting das
kommt noch mal on top und darauf würde
ich auch nicht verzichten weil es gibt
einfach noch mal diese Frische und die
fruchtige Note ihr braucht einfach nur
Erdbeeren und Zucker einmal in den Topf
oder man verlieren die Pfanne geben dann
werdet ihr merken dass die Erdbeeren
irgendwann so ein bisschen in sich
zusammenfallen und ihr könnt sie dann
anschließend pürieren und dann sollten
sie aber circa so 12 bis maximal 15
Minuten einfach so ein bisschen vor sich
hin köcheln damit sie einen reduzieren
und so ein richtig schönes dickflüssiges
Püree entsteht
[Musik]
so das Erdbeerpüree ist schön eingelegt
oh guckt euch das mal an so muss das
sein die Konsistenz brauchen wir und ich
habe es jetzt auch noch mal abkühlen
lassen das ist ja eigentlich alles
abgekühlt und ich nehme mir eine
Lochtülle schon relativ groß also ich
habe die 17 mm können auch 15 mm nehmen
ihr könnt auch meine gar keine Tülle da
habt vorne einfach nur die Spitze
abschneiden aber dann habt ihr links und
rechts so ein Zacken das ist noch nicht
ganz rund und ganz gerade mit einer
Lochtülle ist es einfach ein bisschen
schöner so da fühl ich jetzt meinen
cream cheese Frosting ein dann werden
die Cupcake bespritzt und dann kommt da
einfach nur noch hier unser Erdbeerpüree
oben drauf
[Musik]
so ich habe die muffinförmlich immer
entfernt weil ich finde dann sieht man
auch dass der auch noch mein knusprigen
Boden hat und jetzt einfach nur den
Spritzbeutel richtig schön senkrecht
halten und dann leichten Druck ausüben
könnt ihr eine kleine Runde machen damit
das Frosting auch überall dran kommt so
und jetzt gehen wir ein bisschen vom
Erdbeerpüree ich habe ein bisschen mehr
als ich für die Oberfläche tatsächlich
brauche ein Apple Püree aber das finde
ich gut weil dann kann ich auch auf dem
Teller noch ein bisschen was servieren
so ein Klecks reicht schon und dann
nimmt ihr euch einfach ein Zahnstocher
und dann einfach machen das sieht
richtig lecker aus also richtig zum
anbeißen
[Musik]
Cupcakes mit butterkeksboden und
creampie's Frosting und auch noch Apple
Püree gezauberes
hübsch so dezent aber hübsch und ich
habe es auch noch nie so gesehen noch
nie
Erfindung aber es ist wichtig
cool aus ich würde sagen direkt rein
lassen
[Musik]
gut
knutschen
und Leute es wird richtig gut macht nach
da brauche ich gar keine vielen Worte
mehr
und vor allem dieses ist so eingedickt
ist so intensiv das Frosting hat die
perfekte süße dadurch dass im Teig ein
bisschen weniger
Leute wir können uns wünschen euch einen
schönen Tag bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]